and it is an honor for me to introduce
the gentleman who will present the
Writing Awards one of America's most
eminent dramatists currently writing up
New York with his latest hit small craft
warning and twice winner of the Pulitzer
Prize for a streetcar named desire and
Cat on a Hot Tin Roof and I might add
today Time magazine calls him the man
who is the greatest living playwright in
the Western world mr. Tennessee Williams
well you know we had a rehearsal
yesterday and I got quite a laugh when I
came on and I to myself you know and my
very my representative is also my very
close friend said it was caused by a
white piano on stage being moved but I'm
I don't see that white piano and I'm not
getting the left so I'm going right into
the serious business the serious
business and is a serious business to
everybody concerned of my trying to read
even trying to write is a serious
business
but trying to read is more serious at
this moment I want to see the nominees
names out there so I can read them
Stanley Kubrick for his screenplay of a
Clockwork Orange Bernardo Bertolucci for
his screenplay of the conformist Ernest
Tiedemann for his screenplay of the
French Connection
ergo Pierrot and Victoria Ponticelli for
their screenplay of the garden of the
finzi-continis thank god I've been
dearly Larry McMurtry and Peter
Bogdanovich for their screenplay of the
last picture show and the winner is now
opening envelope and I open read this I
have to change glasses the winner is
Ernest
Tiedemann for the French Connection
thank you very much I called my mother
the other day who said I want to see you
on the stage because I'm going to watch
the calling night I said those other
four guys they got mothers too and I'd
like to say that they wrote those other
four mothers have a lot of pride because
there were many great scripts involved
in this and I'm deeply grateful thank
you